moustaki bonsoir merci d'être venus ce
soir sur ce plateau de soir3 on vous a
vu au début du journal dans cette
chanson célèbre la longue dame brune
c'est une chanson qui a une histoire
aussi ses chansons qui a 30 ans et à
l'époque que j'étais un peu dans une
semi retraite et barbara me faisait
venir chez elle pour que je vais écrire
des chansons et moi je regardais la
télévision parce que je n'avais pas chez
moi
plaisant d'aller chez elle bavarde et
puis elle n'a ce qu il jouera les
munitions crée pas de chansons germain
télévisions choisi pour regret le
registre est à 2 finalement pour laver
le défi j'ai improvisé sur sa personne
je dis bien je vais faire une chanson
pour toi pour une longue dame brune que
tu es et ses bons essais c'est venu
comme ça comme une plaisanterie elle a
répondu la chanson s'est construite
petit à petit et quand on s'est aperçu
que c'est une vraie chanson qu'on veut
la chanter puis nous pas en rougir on a
décidé de l'enregistrer puis de partir
en tournée pour la chanter ensemble
vraiment une chanson qui compte parmi
celles que j'ai fait et même dans ce
répertoire
je sais que les gens évoquent souvent
parce que parce que ça leur présenter ça
ça raconte notre notre intimité notre
connivence
qu'est ce que selon vous il faut garder
ce soir de barbara ont trouvé une
déclaration récemment où justement elle
avait dit qu'elle détestait qu'on
l'appelle une grande dame de la chanson
lisais je suis une famille champ il
soumet une longue dame brune et c'était
la grande dame il est l'ami qu'on parle
d'elle comme personne longue de retenir
celle d'un personnage d'exception dans
notre profession et même de notre
paysage en général parce qu'elle s'est
aligné sur aucune mode sur aucune sur
aucun déchet l'imposé sa sensibilité 100
sans jamais faire la moindre concession
à rien ni à personne et sans aucun sens
aucune ambition dévorante simplement
parce que c'était absolument sa vie le
sens c'est la mort c'était le public les
hommes étaient des passages probablement
je vais en parler avec éloquence parce
que je ne connais pas bien sa vie privée
comme
on a souligné l' été très pudique mais
je crois que son véritable avancée les
publics pour le public à l'aller au
théâtre à 2 heures devrait me dit se
préparer se faire belle être en
condition de lui donner tout ce qu'elle
pouvait lui donner alors ses amis et ses
proches le savaient mais on a peut-être
le sentiment de le découvrir aussi un
peu ce soir c'est à quel point elle
s'était engagée aussi dans un certain
nombre de combats de lutte et elle
souhaitait une discrétion totale sur ces
combats elle n'en parlait jamais
pratiquement non mais où je crois qu'on
ne se bat pas pour pour le polo vitrine
mais si on écoute les chansons il parle
de tous les sujets qui lui tiennent à
coeur soit du racisme gottingen c'est un
peu le la conciliation avec les ennemis
d'hier
elle était très préoccupé par le sida
parce que c'est une puisque l'amour tenu
une place importante de sa vie de voir
que que l'amour pouvait être à ce point
mortels l'a bouleversée lors comme on le
sait ce qu'elles distribuaient des
préservatifs à la sortie des concerts
elle en parler pendant le concert et
c'était la foi s'est imposée lectrices
mme plein de pudeur mais plein de
détermination
georges moustaki merci pour ce
témoignage puis les obsèques de barbara
seront